if you get your back cracked you'll
always need it cracked
oh man i hear this all the time sitting
at a desk
all day will give you bad posture we
need to get away from the notion that
there's one good or one bad
posture massages will remove knots in
your back
first of all the misconception is that
you have knots there to begin with
hi my name is dr tom walters i'm a
physical therapist based in santa
barbara california
and i specialize in the treatment of
patients with general orthopedic
pain and injuries and i am dr david song
and i am a chiropractor
based in toronto ontario and the
patients that i mostly see
are weight lifters and other people who
are experiencing issues with their daily
activities
and today we'll be debunking myths about
posture and back pain
myths people hear growing up good
posture means standing or sitting up
straight
so this is a myth that comes up a lot in
the clinic
there's this really ideal good posture
tuck your chin in pull your shoulders
back the current
pain science injury rehab evidence just
doesn't support
that thinking there isn't really a bad
posture
if you were gonna label a posture as bad
maybe it would just be that posture that
you're in for too long
you get you want to do anything for
eight hours and chances are it's not
going to be comfortable by the end of it
so slouching in itself
is not really the problem it's why
you're doing it for so long or
not even that it's about not doing
anything else really
there's actually some really interesting
research where they actually
put people in slouching and showed that
in the low back it actually improved
nutrient and fluid delivery so we just
have to keep moving
stretching will give you good posture oh
man
i don't think anyone has ever achieved
good posture through stretching
by all means do it it's better than just
sitting there doing nothing
posture is not really determined by how
tight your muscles are
there are a lot of other aspects that go
into posture for sure
genetics are a part of it activities
that you're involved in especially
during development your actual
skeleton will change depending on what
activities
you expose it to in your teenage years
like one that we talk about a lot are
baseball pitchers you know they if they
start at a young age their actual
upper bone their humorous bone and their
arm will actually twist
because of the stresses they're putting
on it we might have
mobility type work or interventions and
stretching could be a part of that
and the only way you can permanently
really probably change your posture is
to be consciously aware of it
all the time and hold that new position
but doing that all the time is probably
going to create other problems for you
so
just be dynamic a stiff mattress is
better for your back there's always
questions about
pillows and mattresses i mean you can
understand we spend a lot of time
sleeping a stiff mattress might be great
for some people
but horrible for other people the best
way you can gauge if something is good
for you is if it's comfortable
this goes with shoes mattresses pillows
all those things so
you really have to think of your own
body almost as an experiment
and test things and see where you're
most comfortable and what's best for
your body
myths from the internet this one should
be a real doozy massages will remove
knots in your back first of all the
misconception is that you have knots
there to begin with
there's not some balled up muscle that
we can mri and see
we have a bunch of muscles that are just
long and skinny and if you rub on them
like this
they feel like a lump don't worry about
it it's just a muscle in your body
so massages can help to loosen up a
tight muscle
it can influence how that muscle feels
and how that muscle
perceives you know digital pressure
applied to
it but will it get rid of the knot well
i mean the knot wasn't there to begin
with so
body braces will fix your posture dave
i'll let you
go first they do have their place don't
get me wrong they can help
assist you in a position that you need
to hold much
like a crush what assists you standing
up
to not weight bear on that broken foot
and so it can
help to deload some of the muscles while
you wear it
they can temporarily improve your
posture while you're wearing them but
when you get any permanent changes is a
totally different story
we need those things sometimes medically
to let something heal but
anytime you have something passive
holding your body it means your
neuromuscular system isn't doing it and
it doesn't need to anymore
those muscles that would have held you
back that are now being held by
something else will quickly atrophy and
decondition so even if that brace
gave you some relief we might say okay
yeah maybe use it temporarily in certain
times of the day or activities but it's
only for short windows it's not a
permanent solution because it's going to
create all kinds of other negative
physical body side effects you want to
be able to condition the body up and
strengthen it as opposed to rely on
something external influence
mris and x-rays can always diagnose your
back problem
oh man i need to buy myself an mri
if that's the case mris and x-rays are
often over utilized for diagnosing back
problems yeah a lot of the research
shows that a structural issue
with mris or x-rays and whether or not
that person has
a disability or pain that correlation is
pretty low
likewise you can have someone
experiencing a lot of pain
a lot of issues and again mri and it's
completely clean it just looks like
a healthy spine when we look at the
spine and spine
pain we don't recommend mris
until the person's done in like a six
week course of rehab because
they've actually found that when people
get those images if there is something
there
it can create fear and anxiety and
they've actually shown that
outcomes in terms of recovery are poorer
when somebody sees their mri
often a patient will be like hey i have
this mri report and i'm like hold up
let me see everything else about you
first but i don't want
to let that mri determine everything
else about you because it's just
one aspect about what you're
experiencing myths we hear the most
sitting at a desk all day will give you
bad
posture we need to get away from the
notion that there's one good or one bad
posture and just really realize that the
research doesn't support that
really the best thing you can do from a
posture standpoint
is just move often change postural
positions often
in the past they've done studies where
they got a bunch of people riding this
recumbent bicycle while doing their desk
work and it turns out that
after eight hours of doing that their
back was killing them
because they're just doing the same
thing for eight hours straight whether
or not
you're sitting moving biking standing
even the treadmill desk guess what if
you're walking for eight hours a day it
might end up hurting your back a little
bit
your nervous system is pretty good about
knowing when you need to change posture
so you just try to take breaks every 38
minutes
every hour something get up and walk
around just changing those stresses
is going to change how your nervous
system perceives your physical body it's
going to change blood flow
it's going to change nutrient delivery
to tissues it's just
implementing the right stresses at the
right time if you get your back cracked
you'll always need it cracked oh man
this i hear this all the time i think
the idea that you need to get your back
cracked once it's cracked
it's rooted in the idea that the
cracking itself
is shifting your bones into place and
that
if you don't get a cracks again it'll
shift out of place and then
you need to get a crack back into place
that in itself is kind of untrue
what we know now is that those cracks
what we call our cavitations
is just gas bubbles being released out
of the joint spinal manipulation is
just about introducing movement back
into those joints it's
literally no different than cracking
your knuckle and then not needing to
crack that knuckle ever again
it's the same mechanism all it is is to
open up a small window of time
where you can move like pain-free or
move with a little bit more ease
and then you know reinforce that type of
movement on your own
let's sum it all up no you you don't
have to get your back cracked
to infinity and beyond wrestling is the
best remedy for back pain
the problem is is that we see that when
people are immobilized or rested for too
long
they just decondition and atrophy and in
some cases it can make the pain system
sort of
ramp up and be more sensitized if they
rest too long rest
is very important when it's needed like
if you just sprained your ankle i'm not
going to get you weight bearing on that
same day
but your the goal is to eventually get
back to
what you're doing pre-injury or even
better than that
rest in itself won't get you there rest
is not rehab this is why when you have
surgery
they don't let you stay in the hospital
and sleep there for multiple nights
anymore you're pretty much in and out
and you're starting
rehab right away and the the best way to
approach
that type of thing is to just slowly
level up your body i think a lot of
people go
from like zero to 100 way too quickly
way too often
your body needs to be symmetrical
another doozy
this is one that comes up a lot
especially on social media
the truth of the matter is asymmetry is
normal there's lots of examples of that
in the body approximately 90
of people for example have a difference
in their leg length we write with one
hand right versus the other we have a
dominant leg where
one legs dominant over the other and our
body adapts to those things so asymmetry
is just a normal part of life
oftentimes i think people are really
quick to write off that their back pain
is because of their scoliosis that might
be an attributing factor but
i would be very cautious to say a
hundred percent it's because of the
structural thing it's
really case-by-case dependent if you
feel pain it always means something is
damaged
such an important one to clear up here
pain is a signal
at its most basic level your body's
saying i don't like that
but it doesn't necessarily mean any
structures damage like the most
easy way to think about is if i just
take my hand here and i just pinch it
that hurts
if i look at my skin nothing's damaged
this has been a really hot
topic in the last 15 years in rehab and
in the pain science research i think
it's really important for people who are
in pain to know
that pain does not necessarily equate to
tissue damage sometimes it does
if you sprain your ankle that pain is
probably associated with tissue damage
but there's so many other cases where
there's not a good correlation between
pain and actual tissue damage this is
why we have a biopsychosocial model now
the bio has to do with tissue
but the psychosocial is other complex
elements and so this is why it's really
important to address
all these other aspects and to
understand uh when you need to
collaborate with another healthcare
professional
in order to increase the outcome of your
patient we all are going to experience
pain at some point i mean if you look at
low back pain
there's an 80 lifetime prevalence which
means 80
of us are gonna have back pain at some
point in our life when people understand
pain
they have better outcomes and they're
less likely to have chronic pain
conditions develop
so it's really important to know that
what matters more than
anything else is like what is your
movement diet looking like like what are
you doing on the daily and how's that
contributing to all the
things that you're feeling